hey
oh ok again a trail
the key result of it hey welcome to the
kira soltanovich show i'm your host Kira
and today at the All Things comedy
podcasts to do my guest is the very
sweet so nice and wonderful and funny
comedic actor game show host papa mr.
Donald Faison yeah he's so great he's
such a sweetheart um it was a while it
was a while for me to our schedules it
was just so hard to schedule and I
wasn't allowed to tell Aaron yeah Aaron
specifically said just don't tell me
when he's coming in yeah I'm a big fan
he's a big fan so then I couldn't even
tell Aaron by the way it was worried you
weren't even coming today cuz I hadn't
told me he'll II guess was oh well no
but this is like our fourth time trying
to get him in here just our schedules
again schedule schedules it's bananas
but we got him in finally and we have a
nice chat no he was really sweet I
forgot to ask him if he does a lot of
podcasts I don't think he has done a ton
I don't think so but really sweet of him
to come in and we had a good time and he
would talk about his kids kids a lot of
kids and I actually saw his little boy
brought his little boy we both brought
our kids to set one day of when sanity
oh my god they're so cute so so cute and
he's a good papa and we worked together
of course on the game show and had such
a great time and I really really hope it
gets picked up so maybe you people
should watch it just watch it come on
don't I want to work together again we
had a really really good time and what a
good time in our conversation so enjoy
my chat with Donald Faison you were like
all right I started dating my wife I was
like look well not gonna get married no
she said to me we're not getting married
oh [ __ ]
said that he was the one that was like
we're not getting married and we're not
having kids wait a minute yes she said
that's how she got me oh she was like I
don't want to get married I don't want
to have kids and I was like perfect
score done and done let's date for a bit
but but she wanted to get married and
have kids eventually yeah like yeah at
that moment she was saying she didn't
want to get married and have kids I
guess it took like yeah uh it was it's
really weird I think she liked Jedi mind
trick me because I was like I perfect
and then you know three years later I
was like we got to move in together and
she was like I don't want to move in
together I was like no we have to do we
move in together we're breaking up just
like I final move in she's genius yes
she's so smart with it and then finally
obtained report was like all right I
know you don't want to get married but
we got to get married and she said I
don't want to get married necessary well
we're getting married and she said I
fine we'll get married what yeah that's
how she did it and but before that I was
like look if we're not gonna get married
at least let's have kids and she was
like I don't want to have kids the day
after we got married we found out we
were having a kid no yes the day after
she would heed on a stick good day after
she peed on a stick she said I think
something's up and it wasn't just the
appetizers and a wedding it wasn't the
advertiser that's so smart I did not
know that I thought it was the opposite
oh I mean that's how you trap a dude she
did it where she Jedi mind trick me into
reverse engineered it yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah you were slow played yeah yeah
exactly exactly ok so we officially met
getting our nails done together we did
but you don't know this I don't but I I
might have told you this one weird we
started shooting yes you were sitting
next to me uh-huh I'm not gonna just you
know disclose our secret nail place yeah
don't talk about I'm not gonna talk
about it but you were sitting right next
to me but it's in Sherman Oaks it's in
studio city but close to Sherman oh
that's like on the border yes and um I
get my mail might have a mailbox right
on that corner ok ok so I went to get my
nails done I walk in it was a middle of
the day during the week so there's like
three people there and one of them
is you know probably the janitor but
he's like sure I'll do your nails like
it's like so slow right and you were
sitting next to me and usually the women
are all up in your business would you
like neck massage and they're always not
you know they're always like would you
like shoulder massage would you like pap
smear nobody even looked at me right
there were like seven women on you yeah
they were so up in your business yeah
they love it they love it and I'm just
sitting there on my house not getting
any love right now so my wife took me to
that place for the first time and the
first time we were there she was like
you know I learned some you know I
learned some korean words and vietnamese
word so i'm going to teach them and one
of the words was like lamb 10 which
means like sex and so when i first got
there I tried to you know I was you know
trying to show up in be funny and I said
I said you know one of the ladies like
so how long you been together and I was
like about you know a month and a half
but we lamb 10 all the time I'm super
lamb 10 and from that moment on they
just all on ya so every time they come
over there do you know every time I we
go over there they're like you know just
you know talk a little uh talk a little
Vietnamese and I'm like lamb 10 long
time that might have been the day I was
there because you were I mean you are
holding yeah you're holding quarter and
I was like can I get a neck massage
they're like not right now round I
talking to this one over here and they
would no one would even look at me yeah
yeah yeah that was just kind of a tip
well too I'm sure you do I'm sure you
throw down a 10 but I've also known
those ladies for a really long time one
time we were hanging out in that when
the nail salon wasn't two rooms just
once the one yeah uh and you know the
police pulled up and came didn't go into
the store but I guess there was a
disturbance next door and they came out
guns blazing not shooting but like dude
[ __ ] the shotgun and nobody in the room
notice and I said oh man that cops got a
shotgun out and I don't know we're just
freaking all of the so
Porter that the freaking Clippers
everything threw up in the air and we
all ran to the back room and uh yeah and
so from that day on we've been real
tight so they know me well I kind of
saved their lives cuz you guys had like
a situation very moment on did you yeah
they probably had some flashbacks to
Vietnam oh god that's what they call me
super lambton super lame silver lefton
back home God yeah you guys were plied
just dating back then this was a while
ago yeah yeah so you have 17 kids
clothes more like six but close close
you have six six kids total okay wow I
thought it was only five no no no six
[ __ ] yes a lot of kids you have to go to
group out in the same ballpark no no no
it's not close huh let me tell you one
of the reasons um I really really really
liked you from the first when the get-go
not the first day we met right when I
took all of your when I took all your
shine did you I mean they weren't giving
you massages or anything like that no oh
you mean that in there no nails by know
the first win sanity run through run
through you which was at GSN house the
first time but then we met at the
offices upstairs we did another
run-through yes and you said something
to me and I was like wow this was it was
it was what everybody I think feels but
no one ever says it right when you have
kids you were like that's what you said
you go here for just um can't sleep at
night because you have anxiety of like
how am I gonna feed these people do you
member saying that I don't I still have
that anxiety but and I was like what
what do you want to talk about I don't
know you're like pacing back and forth
in your legs I don't know just sometimes
I'm like what the [ __ ] how am I gonna
feed these people tell that all the time
yeah and I think that more people should
say that because I always feel like
everybody else has their [ __ ] together
right and I'm the only one that's like
[ __ ] it's not like sometimes I feel like
I'm not renting these kids no these are
mine yeah
hey you feel like one day it's like up
my lease is up but no it's never that
every day every day rest of your life
the rest of your life um yeah some kids
are gonna be asking you for money in
there for I got six of them so so yeah
one of them one of them is gonna be a
[ __ ] up I don't know which one it's
gonna be but one of them is gonna be the
one that's like I don't have a job dad
can I move in with you that's I feel
like game show music should be playing
right now Wow which I know which one it
is you know which one it is no known
your heart no I don't you feel it no
come on Thursday all seem to be doing
really well right now so we'll see it
yeah and I hope not that oldest one is
19 yeah I was very young I'm 42 so what
does that make me 23 when I had him yeah
23 I didn't have him when my baby mama
had him right now you're 23 there's and
there's a newborn baby how much decal
you can't possibly wrap your head around
the fact that if they take care of a
newborn I mean I know that if you're
like if you're some kid and scratch your
ass Arkansas no offense if you're
listening from Arkansas they're so used
to that you don't mean they're like well
where i'm 21 now time to get married and
have kids but you're from you live
you're from here nam from New York
original you show me yours in New York
that this happened this was in New York
I gotcha already out here I was out here
so yeah you know things happen you yeah
things go the way they go when a man and
a woman win a man's a woman right well
when they lay down with each other they
don't even have to love each other but
when they lay down with each other
things happen yeah and when a woman
lambton right when right no doubt my
errands here for the callbacks thank you
very much uh yeah you know it we weren't
expecting to be together forever at
least right I wasn't expecting I don't
think she was either and you know we had
a she got pregnant and I was our when
she got pregnant I was already on my way
to Los Angeles to film clueless but we
knew it wasn't gonna work
and you know there it is and so you know
it's stressful it's it's not easy he's
19 now so he's a grown-up but um does he
come out too I wish he came out you know
there's a whole lot of things that
people don't tell you about parenting
and one of them is you know it's hard to
do it when you're not with the person
that yeah you know you had the kid with
and it's really hard to do it actually
especially when you live on two coasts
and we've had our we've had our issues
you know he and I you know sometimes
don't get along sometimes we do get
along and yeah you know I hate to bring
the the comedy down but yeah that's the
truth well we can just wrap it up here
let's wrap it up and that's a wrap it's
the 22nd podcast um no you know we just
I just talked to Eddie Brill who's a
comic and he just found out like when
his kid was 13 that he had a son Wow now
now he's you know that was what did he
say 16 years ago so you know he's right
he's grown it now but all of a sudden he
meets a thirteen-year-old right that's
crazy right that's crazy I didn't
imagine that that that's also like a
whole nother like get your mind wrapped
around yeah that like what do you say
like how did he not know like what was
the beef that big between him and it was
a it was you know he laid down really
lambton he lantana lamb 10 long time and
then and then 10 years later wow I yeah
so they and I guess you know he's made
it up to him in there and they're very
close but a guy like I had another comic
bill Dawes one of my favorite episodes
um also found out just randomly Wow just
read like a chick just called him was
like you have an 11 year old wow yeah
that's crazy it's just that's just crazy
so it's it's not the same it's different
but it's a sense of like okay so i have
this person right but I'm not part of
the day in and day out because your two
youngest ones I mean your day and day
and
day out it even even the ones in between
that I have twins and I have a I have a
better 17 and then I have a 15 year old
and even early on when I was married to
their mom that was day in and day out it
was go to the job come home watch the
kids go to like a lot of people think
that you know because you work you get
like you know if you're the dad you get
time off from the kids once you get home
because you had a hard day's work that's
[ __ ] now you come home you jump
right into the fire with your spouse or
with you know however it is and that
should I remember being I was 25 26 at
that time and I remember being like I
want to go to the clubs I don't want to
be home i want to have the club and uh
yeah and I'm divorced from that lady now
so it didn't really go that well right
so did you feel like you missed out on
those under-20s on the 20s and 30s no I
didn't miss out i think that's why I'm
divorced I think obviously that's why
I'm no longer with my ex-wife uh right
but you had kids take care of so you
couldn't go to the club okay oh did you
go out to the [ __ ] yeah no no in the
club at night when the kids went down
and wife went to sleep I was like I see
you later I mean club but then you can't
function the next day no I mean yeah I
would go to work the next day you know
to me [ __ ] I was I was hardcore from
like 26 to 31 32 right up to when I met
my 34 wiped when I met Casey whenever it
was that we meant I was yeah I was nuts
I was caught up wow man you were working
and i was working yeah I can't ok so I
have a spot tonight at the ice house on
the ten o'clock show yeah and I'm I want
to burst into tears because I know that
that's gonna [ __ ] me up for like three
days right yeah I don't know how you
could even I could find was a lot
younger to me I was 26 I'm all your 26
now so you know I know yeah
look I embrace it I totally talk I'm 42
as well okay I talk about my age all the
time I think it's [ __ ] that women
can't I won't tell you much I weigh [ __ ]
that okay but but you know so many times
people lie and they get caught up in
their lives dudes have lied to me hmm
like who the [ __ ] cares how old you are
a good day matters nobody cares anymore
nobody cares right and I think those
days are past I mean I'm not gonna be a
non janu anyway no one's gonna cast me
in that anyway so why would I lie it why
would it be like no I'm 30 I don't know
listen I would allowed to be an out of
lied to be in Star Wars you know what I
mean I would have told them I was you
know 26 if they ask me even with even
with my IMDB I'll be like [ __ ] what that
should say yeah it's will you actually
could pass for that I wish dude I've saw
uh what's his name uh what's the dudes
name blacked up hill harper yeah has
been lying about his age forever I'm put
you on blast hill you lying how do you
know I just know I mean there there are
people who tried to sue IMDb because I'm
to be won't take your age off of the
page that's crazy which I don't even
understand why it what what do they get
out of it they're just being dicks we
can find out anywhere it doesn't matter
anymore what is IMDb why does IMDb do
that why do they make it so easy to put
credits on right so hard to take credit
can't take him off what is that about I
have soft core porn on my IMDB page
really they won't take it off this is
truth one hundred percent Wow yeah I
this was my first week in Hollywood well
first week I was a complete idiot oh you
did softcore porn for real but hold on
hold on let me tell you what happened oh
this is my first like I graduated from
San Diego State yeah uh spent you know a
little bit of time in San Diego but then
I was like I'm moving to LA right I get
a call from a friend of mine that went
to San Diego State with me huh and he
goes hey do you want to be an extra and
I said what's an extra didn't even know
what an extra was right he's like oh
it's a background person
you see in the background of like TVs
movie TV shows and are you having a
heart attack what's happening I think so
hey all right yeah I'm good okay um
what's an extra what supports an extra
right and and so he told me what it was
and he goes and i'll give you like I
know 50 bucks cash and I was like fifty
dollars are you kidding me right yes
whatever it is I'll do it so I go down
to this is so cliche this studio deep in
the valley oh boy it's like a warehouse
oh boy and I walk in and there's other
people there and there's cameras and
cable and I was like oh my god I'm on a
real set right and and he goes okay so
you're gonna be a it's a chemistry
student okay so you have like your
chemistry set and you have like some
books and a backpack and you're gonna
stand at this locker and when they say
action you open up the locker and you
put like your books inside and all that
and I was like great no problem yeah
what's my motivation and that was it oh
okay they gave me 50 bucks cash nice and
I left right on my stepsister uh huh is
up in the middle of the night watching
TV a couple months later and she sees
the minute she turned on the TV you know
she just like the minute my name right
student kira soltanovich and the credits
or she's like what right and she looks
to see what it was and it's like erotic
confessions oh boy and so then she stays
up to watch the room next door because I
go there and it like played it like you
know 3 i'm again something on skinemax
right and this is before you know DVRs
and so she watches it's like oh my god
she's the whole time she's like what is
she doing right was she done and she
said she didn't even see me but you were
but you were but I I was just a reddish
wasn't looking for a background player
she's looking for someone you know
getting their titties fakes up right
right right well I don't know if it's
great now the titties are real sex right
i buy everything else in a traffic yeah
so I told her I go I have no idea what
you're talking about no idea the driver
san i put it together no I've never seen
then I put it together
then I am DB comes out like I don't know
whenever they don't know whenever that
yeah and it's my first credit erotic
confessions it's still there Wow to this
day well you were in it actually though
so it's a credit that you wasn't well
even was I'm just saying I've been back
strap hey hey your friend thought he was
hooking you up maybe by giving you a
credit I could her into after or sag
whatever the union is were erotica truth
be told I was not wearing pants ok no no
I was fully dressed and nothing I just
feel like it was so quick who the [ __ ]
gave me that credit right which line
producer on a soft corvo's again let's
just focus on its give her a bone right
now and imdb's like nope and I've asked
them several times now at this point in
my career is just funny and it's a funny
story to tell right maybe I'll tell it
like on a late-night talk-show couch one
night right but at the time when that
was your only thing right it would she
been in let's look I'm DB let's just
bring her injustice to see you casting
couch yeah I'm on IMDb for things that I
have I'd like Uncle Buck I was never an
uncle buck for some reason IMDb has me
in Uncle Buck for some reason IMDb has
me on the Bernie Mac show I never did me
a racist I know it's like well he must
have been right he must've been on
Bernie Mac black people were ombre Mac I
wasn't I was one of the few black people
I wasn't on burning back and then Uncle
Buck the kid looks like me I'll say that
but I was a lot younger when that movie
came out then that kid the kids playing
a high school student I don't even think
I was in high school when Uncle Buck
came out oh not the TV show uncle no no
no no no the movie Uncle Buck with john
candy and cuz didn't they redo the TV
show they did you mike epps it did
really well for ABC dan still got
canceled really yeah sucks well [ __ ]
IMDb then IMDb is you know it's the
worst it's I'm not gonna say it's the
worst but I'm saying it's the worst have
you ever try to add something on there
no ok so you don't know no I've tried to
take stuff off it's what I have a sure
film on there okay but Aaron have you
ever tried to add I tried to add all my
cast and crew from my one hour special
it's the most not include shut up I did
audio I'm so sorry I already apologized
oh right by the way I've also seen a
classmate in Cinemax series what like an
erotica series what was the name of the
series I don't know who was sent back
mate it's yeah sharina something right
oh and she was real I Creole II with the
background oh and she also got credit
yeah oh come on i think they credit
everyone then well then that's stupid
that's come on yeah 50 bucks too I did
it did you get a t-shirt why would I get
it I don't know that's usually what like
when you get 50 bucks and you usually
get a t-shirt did you ever have to do
any of those shitty crappy erotic jobs
no not erotica is but just like yeah
there were a bunch of job as I did where
I was like I can't believe I'm doing
this I'm not gonna say any names but
yeah I've done quite a few jobs where
I'm like this was not what you told me
this was gonna be like some crazy
independent film yeah where it was like
you know someone said to me this is this
is the script you have a really small
role in it you're gonna be in it and
then I sign on they said well we're
gonna make some rewrites and maybe make
your part a little bit bigger then I get
to set and all of a sudden I'm working
throughout the whole movie damn near and
it's like Oh for fifty bucks well not
for fifty bucks no paid me well but
still it was just like hold on i thought
i was getting paid well to just show up
for two days i'm getting paid well to
show up for you know you you're gonna
get your money's worth now you know what
I mean yeah and uh and yeah that's
happened to me and that wasn't fun so
they k seed you what is Casey do you
mean that's your wife that is my wife oh
they went about him gotcha that is my
wife I guess I get the joke now yes they
totally casein me they can't see ya
you're like no no just we just want you
for something small right and then it
turned and then yeah and they're like
it's called the Donald Faison show well
it wasn't a Donald Faison show but I did
get I was third build in it I would like
to get third billing which was like I
don't even think I was supposed to get
billing in this I was the smallest role
that was you know
it happened I am to be what will give
you Billy yeah no matter what the no
matter what no matter what I I'm gonna
start a campaign all right yeah down
with the down with the DB what's the DB
0 down with the IMDb got down with the
DB we're taking them down you're gonna
take them down I thought you were saying
you were down now I'm do you want to see
my room they there they drive me crazy
good luck I'm gonna wish you luck but in
this day and age there should be
something better that's all I'm saying
speaking of IMDB uh we have an IMDB
credit in common you insanity have you
been watching I have a little bit I have
a little bit too yeah it's good let me
tell you let me tell you though he would
shoot for people listening one episode
well in the beginning an hour and a half
to take two to one episode yeah and
there was a lot of like chit chattin and
having fun and making jokes and then
they whittle it down to like hey yeah
and that's it that's it there's no yeah
there's zero banter all the dangers yeah
all the fun stuff and all your dancing
when we were the singing wasn't gonna
make it right but everything was just
whittled down to all right yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah there was so much good
stuff just just so the show could be
played I think it's I think it's
necessary I mean I don't know about I
don't know if you noticed but we got a
pretty old audience on that network yeah
we had some we have said no I'm talking
about right now while it's airing we
have like 0 are our 18 to 49 is good but
our 50-plus is really good Rioli n so
they're gonna sell some venture right
they love someone sanity really it's
crazy the grown-ups you know was
interesting actually the first night we
watched it i was watching my husband and
immediately he got into it really
immediately he's like oh oh this is hard
i don't know well that's a good sign
yeah well hopefully they bring us back
we'll see we'll see they better they
don't they don't I know but they come on
I mean what what else they got my idiot
test idiot test is great but that's in
wars they need they need us they do need
us yeah and they need us to say more
than just
hey hey Kira hey Donald let's get to the
game shall we cut I know it's okay yeah
I'd hurt my heart yeah there was so much
good stuff and then people don't know
this but the audience I mean they don't
like we're like half the show yeah and
they're cut down to nothin yeah zero
crazy that's the thing I was like well
don't we have like can't we make gifts
out of some of the stuff or little short
videos out of the some of the stuff that
we did and just put it up so people can
see that we did some funny stuff that we
were funny yes they're like and I guess
GSN won't do it they haven't done it yet
yeah so I had to talk to the fine people
at GSN because they were sending me
stuff to help me promote they're like
hey can you promote this week and they
would send me a picture of like an
audience member right and I said you
know just a heads up if you send me a
picture of me right since I'm on the
show it kind of might make more sense
and then and then oh and then someone
brought me up on stage and they said the
host of wind sanity and I was like no no
that's Donald I'm his sidekick and then
that got put into a meme and then
someone on Twitter was like how dare you
say you're the host and I was like oh
boy how did that have it in two seconds
that's how it happens Wow into into
second that is I mean I would I would
have still owned it though I'm just
joking like yeah I do host it Joe it's
just been cut it's been cut down yeah
y'all don't see is that it's been cut
down the way it happened was Donald came
in for like two seconds right and they
cut around me hosting it and make it
look like he hopes editing is everything
right no I'll be honest that those 10
days or two weeks that we did those were
probably some of the most insane
shooting I've ever done I was on I had
the Zika virus did you have Zika I don't
know i had but remember how sick I was
do remember how sick you are yes [ __ ]
and you had a sick baby too at home at
home wasn't sleeping that was not
sleeping so I wasn't sleeping right I
was um and you know and you weren't
taking any antibiotics or anything no
because I'm a lunatic and I'm a hippie I
know I
oh you were looking at me crazy yeah but
I what I had some sort of h1n1 wow I had
like the swine bird flu all of it
together Wow awful h1 you had pig flu
and bird flu all of them I Old MacDonald
read our own version of everything you
had like if you were to travel overseas
you'd have to fill out the card that
said yes I've been on the phone I
haven't been on the farm and I have
finger to pig and that's why I'm so sick
right I got this pig HIV I don't know
why I did it pig aids but I got so sick
and and we it wasn't like I could be
like hey I can't come in today right
right we had we had to push through push
through five shows a day yeah and I
don't know how you didn't get sick I
didn't get sick because I stayed away
from you I guess I don't know how I get
sick I don't know but you did not get
sick funding liat signo but um then one
day I guess they heard in my ifb over my
mic I was talking to the stage manager I
said oh man I just coughed up some blood
you didn't know I didn't know this holy
[ __ ] up fred was that his name Fred the
job yes like oh cuz they were like
giving me these cups cup of tea but I
thought that was TV and then i would
call phlegm into it gotcha it was
disgusting God and so I go oh man I look
down and I ah I just coughed up some
blood right away in my ear the executive
producer was like cured do you need a
doctor right and I said yeah and
remember they brought a an acupuncturist
set I remember the acupuncturist and
after that day I got so much better
right on after that day acupuncture
really works like that yes you don't
believe in it I don't it's not that I
don't believe in it i just i mean i
guess there's proof to it cuz of a lot
of people do it but yeah it just doesn't
I don't understand how a needle in your
back can change a virus in your system
oh my god it can but it does like it
really does well but that's the thing is
that I know that I seem crazy to people
no la can't be no I can't seem crazy no
not crazy I just
when i get my throat hurts and when my
nose is running or something like that i
go to the doctor and try again an
antibiotic yeah probably bad for my
system and I'm the complete opposite
right so remember your set your child
was sick your daughter right was
coughing coughing coughing coughing my
son I think it was Oh was your son baby
and you were like yeah it's just been
coughing for ever and ever and I I might
have even like said something again I
never pushed on people cuz then I think
people think I'm like shaking chicken
bones and like I go to my crazy much
doctor the bones say but i might have
said like well maybe you might look into
acupuncture I might have said that I
might have and you were like and I think
you might have been like yeah that's
crazy no I don't know I don't remember
that I take my kids to acupuncture yes
do they love it no yeah they hate it
yeah but it works it works right on
somebody told me something about putting
wet socks on your kids feet when they're
going to sleep wet wool socks and that
pulls especially when they have fever or
something like that I probably told you
about the onions you did tell me about
the onions yes you put onions in their
room again it's not like a cure-all in
like two seconds right but I don't know
I feel like with kids I i revert back to
my Soviet upbringing okay and I don't
jump on antibiotics with kids right and
with adults it's like do whatever you
want to do that's fine it's you're an
adult but I just feel like with kids I
do everything that my crazy Russian
grandmother would do brush she used to
put garlic up my nose that's cool but
people don't think that's cool they
think it's crazy right they think like
why are you don't what are you doing
like just get your kids some medicine
right but I'm I know I'm I said hey to
everybody is different my dad used to
make us I mean I didn't drink cereal
with sugar and a habit drink I didn't
eat cereal with sugar in it until I was
like 21 years old you know I mean what
did your dad make you do we had to like
you know oats and yeah we couldn't have
milk it would have to be apple juice or
it was like really weird like he
make it so that and it couldn't be like
apple juice from you know the grocery
store it had to be like homemade apple
juice it was like he was really into you
know we didn't take pills like
antibiotics he would make us take
vitamins all the time and you know for a
really long time I didn't get sick and
then you know as an adult finally one
day I got like you know cold or the flu
and somebody was like here take take
these antibiotics and october take the
antibiotics and went away right away and
I was like yo forget everything my dad
used to say I'm gonna do it this right
now but I remember for a really long
time I didn't get sick like i'ma say
from I'll say from 17 to maybe 23 it was
rare that I was like oh I can't move I
can't move brand I think it had
everything to do with how my dad built
my immune system yeah with all of the
stuff he would give us yeah halcyon
pills we had to take alfalfa cod liver
oil oh that's good don't like where's
your dad from that he he just don't
write all this he he he's I don't know
when I was younger they thought i had
like leukemia or something like that
when I was born and I remember spending
a lot of days in the hospital and he
went to a doctor who was like all right
let's check his surroundings and see
what's going on turned out I was
allergic to cats and we had cats okay
and you know he was like all right let's
take him off of instead of giving him
antibiotics let's just keep some
room-temperature yogurt out put some
yogurt out let it get to room
temperature if he ever experience as an
earache or you know what I mean like
that you just eat the yogurt now not
saying leave the yogurt out all day I'm
saying take it out of the the the
frigerator put it down for the
acidophilus well i don't know i guess i
guess yogurt turns into an antibiotic on
its own when it's in when it's room
temperature okay and this is the first
time i've ever heard that yeah and i am
a crunchy tree hugger really yes but
that but that's what i would have to do
instead of taking antibiotics if i had
an earache or you know
I I don't know if it would be an can I
don't know if you could call it a ear
infection right but if my ear was
hurting way I would be like all right
hold on twenty minutes later eat the
yogurt really and then it would go away
yeah what yeah yeah and he's from where
some news forum DC originally Washington
DC but when he moved to New York and and
I was misdiagnosed to have leukemia and
it wasn't leukemia that seems like a
really yeah big mistake mistake where
it's like you trip and you fall and you
scrape your knee and they're like we
gotta amputated right exactly what yeah
yeah yeah and then he went to a doctor
who didn't believe in all of that stuff
and there was so you you have that too
then you were brought up that way too I
was that's why I don't that's why I
don't judge you when you say a coupon
works and stuff like that okay I believe
that's fine if it works for you it works
I remember it I remember doing stuff
like that I remember watching my mom get
acupuncture and really oh so it all
comes out yeah but yet you wouldn't do
that for your kids I totally would I
don't know if my wife would and she runs
the show you know what I mean yeah let's
keep it real you know I would totally be
like yeah let's try some holistic and
let's try some all natural let's try the
all-natural way she's not into it I mean
she hasn't seen it work yet though you
know what I mean so when I tell her
stories about when I was a kid she's
like your parents are hippies were your
parents hippies pretty much yeah without
the drugs yet pretty much in new york in
new york and you have other siblings i
do same thing like you can ask them you
know apple juice and cereal is probably
the nastiest thing I've ever heard of in
my life but then when I finally started
drinking milk all of a sudden I had
sinus problems oh I see okay so is the
dairy it wasn't just dare it was a bunch
of things you know what I mean like I
had a cousin who couldn't drink orange
juice because he broke out and it I
guess he was allergic to aren't I guess
he was allergic to oranges at the end of
the day but you know that was a big
thing that's where we got our source of
vitamin C from like naturally squeezed
orange juice and you know I took a lot
of pills grown-up not like doctor pills
but like vitamins right right right
right I'm rambling tits
good no no I love all this you know
because it's like when I think of how I
want to raise my kids um for example my
one-year-old doesn't know anything right
now she just she looks at me she goes
you look familiar that's all she knows
right right but the five year old is
catching on so if he if he has a cold he
knows he's going to dr. Jing right he
knows right and I like our pediatrician
but our pediatrician can't really do
anything for him except for prescribe
something something over the counter
right exact an a pediatrician really do
okay look in your ears Oh ear ear sir oh
you have an infection oh I can see in
your nose and your mouth oh it's swollen
whatever okay great and then what right
did not subscribe you with an any
product only prescribe that's all they
can do I mean this sorry okay a
chiropractor right can make an
adjustment a chiropractor can actually
physically do something again I'm not
pushy anything but I do have a three-day
weekend I'd love for you to be a part of
ok Howie um sie diesen code I used to go
to chiropractors also is that like I
remember one time I was watching a like
the Emmys or something in and an actress
was onstage and she was standing kind of
funky my dad's like that girl need to go
to the chiropractor or not yeah like
what why yeah cuz she's old she got all
sorts yeah I guess that's when you get
sick you go to the chiropractor to us
Wow yes adjustments i get i go to the
chiropractor by the way ear infections
chiropractic ira pract right yes right
all of all i'll just give me your
chiropractors information he is i would
love attention studio city studio city
oh yes all right now just dr. Bennett
okay the only thing about dr. Bennett is
and I say this to his face i'm not
talking to school is he looks a little
bit like a um he like he works in a big
top like he he had is like a penguin
crazy mustache i love dr. Bennett but
I'm always like don't you ever want a
penguin tuxedo top how do you have time
doing adjustments when you're busy tying
people to train tracks
always [ __ ] with him no but he's great
dr. Patrick Bennett he is very fast he's
very quick you bring in all four of you
he'll put you in a room and he's just
like but he had just series like bye see
you later he doesn't [ __ ] around he
doesn't have to take x-rays although he
can if you want it but he doesn't have
to [ __ ] around he just goes crack crack
crack crack all right have a great
weekend now I've sent people to him in
there like well I didn't like the fact
that he didn't sit there and ask me what
my favorite color was [ __ ] he has
enough time for that he is quick and he
is fast and he gets the job done and he
doesn't waste your time ok so if you're
looking for someone to like hold your
hand and talk to you about ponies it's
not him nokay he is very he's busy he's
busy he always has people in his office
all that time should give me his yes and
he's fantastic and he adjusted my baby
when she was three weeks old and what
happened after that I mean nothing but
when a baby comes out of you've watched
the babies come out yes yeah it's not
it's not like a TED ah look I got I mean
it's crazy oh yeah I need so he talks
about how you know when you can adjust
them a little bit you kind of give them
a little relief from what Rama been
through yes both my kids were adjusted
like within the first month of their
lives Wow yeah i mean it's it's not what
you think it is no no it's not a
cracking rogers basically pulls ya heap
holds them upside down oh that's it
that's it I'll show you I can show you
okay it's really it's actually pretty
cute okay but it's if it's your first
time if you think that he's trying to
murder more David yeah he's not trying
to murder I promise you he will not try
two more I'm gonna find it right now
okay um but anyways so that's what i
like to hear that that's how you were
raised you got this how I was raised the
minute I got out of the house so I
changed everything for me because I
could and it was like oh no cuz you
could Rebello yeah my friends were
eating freakin cocoa puffs and stuff
like that and I wanted to eat cocoa
puffs I didn't want to just eat sea oats
that's one of the things that I do worry
about is when you become that parent
that's like the no sugar parent
then that's all they want that is
absolutely correct because I was brought
up um I was but I'm gonna find it for
you I was brought up with you could
drink all the alcohol you wanted really
yeah I parent to like do you dream you
know yeah saying zero desire to drink I
know people who were brought up like
that and they're raging alcoholics okay
so it could go either way yeah but I I
can't find it now but I'll find it um I
my parents were like please bring
friends we have plenty plenty vodka we
keep it in freezer never locked it up
all my other friends houses vodkas
locked up right like lines to delete you
know to me like don't drink and then
they would add water cuz your parents
are idiots right why are you adding
water I would've han tell I would even
tell them I'll bring you vodka from my
house and just add vodka so that you
don't get busted and and they're my all
my friends were like oh my God we're
going to your house to drink I was like
whatever I don't care my parents never
cared and so it was never a big deal
yeah I mean I my brother went to school
with a Russian basketball player they
were on the same basketball team
together and he said you know and they
went to school in like the Springfield
Mass and in a winter it got cold and he
would come out in a sweater and
everything like that but he drank vodka
I think he was all for 18 though yeah
but I mean was never like if we ever
catch you drinking vodka we send you
back to Siberia nothing like that there
was never like it was just like sure
everybody everybody drinks it yeah let's
go now yeah all the timing and so but my
fear is like cuz I I I don't let my kid
have a lot of sugar but then he's gonna
do what you did yeah you're just gonna
go crazy that's a possibility or he
could go into life thinking you know
what I don't need sugar but I guarantee
once he has that first real taste of
sugar oh thats thing that takes you to
the edge oh babe way if they would never
introduced sugar ever to the population
and then all of a sudden introduced it
right now I'd probably be stronger than
crack we would all be blowing each other
for sugar yes easy easy
pz I'm dead serious i really believe
that just that but do you let your kids
just have no no i did for a bit and my
wife was like you know you gotta ruin
them and it turned into a you know we
had a month where the kid was crying cuz
i wouldn't give him snacks and i was
given because i gave him snacks for like
what snacks like you know I was stupid
so I would give him like you know I
bought fruit loops once and that was the
biggest mistake of my life because I
gave him fruit loops and you know to
this day he's still like fruit loops and
it's like no you're gonna have cheerios
he's like okay I tried yeah you know but
yeah yeah I that was the biggest mistake
I think fruit loops and you know cookies
and you know ice cream all those things
that you think this is gonna be my kids
gonna love me for this I'm the cool dad
for this it actually turned and bites
you in the ass really fast it's the
worst possible thing yeah I could do
yeah it really is it really is you not
only destroy the training that you've
done up until that point to make it so
that they don't grab stuff but we had
issues with like Rocco where we go to
parties and they'd you know put cake and
stuff out you know as a display and he
just walk up to the [ __ ] and grab it
walk off with a cupcake and it was like
no dude that's not that's not how it
works but it was because he was getting
sugar that he was like oh it's okay for
me to take this that's crackhead
behavior that's crackhead that is kind
of crackhead ish right and you know once
we got him off the sugar that doesn't
happen anymore where we can have they
can have a set up now and he won't pay
attention to it but for like you know
their early parts of his life at two he
just didn't you know I've made the
mistake of thinking if I give him sugar
he'll be happier and all it did was just
made it matter no angry you know you
know hard to put him down and hard to
control and you know it was my fault
remember my wife been like you're
ruining our kid and me thinking no I'm
not and at the end of the day I was
totally wrong were you secretly trying
to bribe him I mean I just wanted him to
like me more than he liked her three
honest with you let's keep it real you
know what I mean but yeah I sometimes
feel like I throw my husband under the
bus and I don't mean to do it but I am
aware of it I'm trying to be better yeah
but I do sometimes feel like I throw my
husband under the bus like how like if
he disciplines are the five year old um
oh this is so awful I'll be like come
here come here come and I'll comfort him
it's so bad it's bad that's bad I'm
trying to be like mama mama but I will
discipline him to my biggest thing I
have to so focused on the worst good so
I'm the worst right but you know what it
is I have a constant conflict with
parenting it's a constant push pull
which is I have my angry Soviet voices
in my head where everything can be
solved with hit right which I'm like
shut up voices right I'm constantly like
I'm not listening to you I'm [ __ ]
bipolar in my head when it comes to
parenting right and then the other part
of me which is I'm gonna make your
childhood different from mine
everything's gonna be better for you you
know it means so like it's like the easy
way that I know which is like get over
here which I I try not to do and then
the overcompensation right because that
is in my head am I making any sense
absolutely so so when my husband does
discipline him which sometimes it's one
hundred percent deserved and he needs to
learn and that's how we need to teach
kids they need to hear a difference
differentiation of our voice huh because
if they just hear us say everything in
lollipop unicorn voice right they're
never gonna know danger right um but
also I feel like oh you were upset and I
go back to my childhood immediately and
you're like I can fix this with a hug
and is that's the worst that I mean I
don't think it's the worst I think it's
kind of messed up to do to your husband
right after he's disciplined them but
hey totally [ __ ] I'm not say I do it
every time right but I catch myself I'm
aware of it nice but you know you do it
I know I do it okay yeah I mean it's
listen and
I'll try and bargain with my kid my kid
will say I want a cookie my wife will
say no you can't have a cookie I'll say
but I'll give you half a cookie and then
my wife will say are you crazy don't
give him any cookies I said no cookies
and I'm consistently saying sorry to her
and then sorry to him and then sorry to
the girl sorry I do the same thing yeah
you know what I call it I call it just
the tip when you drink some teas it's
such a tease such a to you I go all
right I'll give you half right just the
tip that's such a tease so cuz it's like
it's something right but it's not what
you really want fun all in one right
yeah but just the tip turns into the
whole thing usually usually the game
just tip it's the whole thing and then
again you're in trouble yes [ __ ] now
it's gonna be impossible to take it away
from you next time or right it's like we
made a mistake like my kid showed an
affection for trash trucks and we were
like all right let's get him some trash
trucks because he looks real one cuz I
don't you're about how we roll that's
how we roll he loves the gear but no so
we got him a bunch of toy trash trucks
and we realized this is we just spoiled
the crap out of him we just kind of
ruined him for doing that in by doing
that you know if anything we could have
got him something cooler like a fire
truck or or just one right or just one
trash or just why yes three he has three
yeah I totally get it yeah again is that
you compensating did you not have enough
toys as a kid I had plenty of toys as a
kid but it's just you know your kid says
he wants something and you want to try
and do your best to give him what they
want what I didn't have growing up with
a lot of money and so you know
immediately it's like you know there
were certain things would be like I want
this and I couldn't have like I want
sneakers and I couldn't get the sneakers
I wanted or I want you know I remember
one year I wanted the millennium falcon
for my birthday and my parents were like
no you're not going to get the
Millennium Falcon we can't afford it
they got it for me anyway but I remember
being like I never want my kid to feel
like I felt when I was told I couldn't
get the Millennium Falcon yeah I mean
and so uh yeah man I
when he says you know he wants hotwheels
the racetrack I'll go out and I'll buy a
freakin of you know a hot wheel set the
size of this room that we're in right
now and have him play with that and he
doesn't need all of that how we just
need to track and the African car and
that's it and not in that right but in
my head on my own I named my head I'm
like listen I gotta do this for this kid
cuz he's asking for it and I didn't and
when I asked for stuff like this as a
youth I rarely got it you know I mean
you know my parents were getting a
divorce or not a divorce they were
slowly splitting up and it took them
four years Wow so um but when I graduate
from high school right around that time
and then it took them until I graduate
from college Wow oh [ __ ] five years
that's me five years to master good for
you good for you yet fun stretch yeah um
so uh my senior year pictures um I told
my mom oh I want to order some pictures
my mom said no I was like what do you
mean no she's like we're you know
because they were in the process and
it's like stressful and money and
lawyers and all this stuff and she said
no and I go what do you mean no right
she's like we don't have the money for
senior year pictures and I remember I
was like how much does it cost to get
pictures like some wallet-sized so cuz
all your friends are getting each other
pictures you know remember me remember
me and my parents were like no they just
kept saying no so I had to pass out the
samples with sample across my face wow I
sure to certain friends it's only have
like five of them yeah yeah well yeah I
happen to have like I don't know
whatever like 10 samples right and i
passed out samples to all my friends and
I was like and as I passin I'd like my
[ __ ] parents now looking back right
I'm a parent I get it financially it's
tough I get it but at the time I was
like [ __ ] this I was so pissed at them
right
like how could you not have your [ __ ]
together right but guess what I was 17 I
I had jobs I could have you could have
got it just I could have got it myself
but that in that moment I was like I'll
never make my kids pass out samples yeah
oh dude would you make him pass out
samples now yeah even if you were going
to or you would yes holy cow I would I
wouldn't because well now they can just
text it to now exactly now it's like
I'll just tag you on facebook right
right no it's not that pass out samples
it's that it's that what it represents
right it's like if well I don't have
something in this moment I can't just
magically that's just where we're at
right how do we learn how did you learn
that lesson as an adult with your kids
though what we mean now like yeah if you
want something how did you how do you
just like it's hard for me to look at my
kid he doesn't even have to cry he could
just be like daddy I want this and I'll
be land i'll look at it and i've said no
several times but there's that no
there's those few times room just like
[ __ ] it I'm gonna get it I don't care I
don't care if I get in trouble for this
I'm gonna get it and I wind up doing it
I just for first of all if we can't we
can't right right so my kid wanted to
take like five different classes he's
like I want to do a little league I want
to go martial arts I want to do soccer
like he named like five different things
and my husband are like all right well
all of those things are like at least
300 bucks this kid wants us to throw
down fifteen hundred dollars it's not
happening no and I go you can pick one
and he was disappointed i go pick one
what did he pick Marsha lights no good
for him yeah so he did martial arts and
he's like I want to go back now and I go
you're gonna have to wait all right yeah
you're gonna have to wait lets us out
let's see let's assess the situation
exactly but it's hard yeah but it's it's
the reality we can't make things happen
when they're just not that I can't write
a bad check I'm not gonna do that now
that's just not the paper but it's hot
it's hard it makes me feel ya it's no I
totally get it I totally get it uh my
brother has a kid who plays soccer and
he's really good at it
and every year whoo-whee cloud my
brother for this too but you know every
year he sends out an email like listen I
can't afford soccer this year you guys
all see how good this kid is and how
much he loves it if you could that would
be great if you could help us in so you
know affording you know he'll write a
letter to me my mother my father my
brother some of his cousins like just
like if i could get such and such from
from you guys I could totally put this
kid in soccer again like the kids really
really like we've all seen how good this
kid is well wait a second how much does
soccer cause its shoes no it's also he
plays club soccer so so soon yes so he
has to pay dues yesterday for his
uniform he has to play for travel pay
for travel y espero ok ok and it's very
expensive expand its really expensive
yeah but the kids so good yeah i mean
like he's so good he excels at it you
know what I mean he's better than like
every time on his team he's one of the
better players yeah and a Saigon we
gotta you gotta yeah and I know it's you
know I know it's not you know I know my
brother's like this is embarrassing it I
do this every year right no I mean even
when he has a job even when he's making
money he's like this is way too
expensive for me to just pay straight up
I cannot tell you the happy dance I'm
gonna do in a couple of weeks when my
kid starts LA Unified really free free
school we have been paying for private
school crazy right for years I can oh my
god it's a lot of money it's a lot of
money yeah and that's the thing it's
like you know it's again I don't know if
you were brought up with parents that
screamed or yelled or were stressed or
whatever but my whole it was like there
was a lot of stress a lot of stress so I
just if he doesn't feel half the stress
that I felt I'll be you've done your job
I'll be happy yeah because i don't i
don't know if you guys you guys yell in
the house or not but we try not to like
i can't really I mean my wife and I we
fight every now and then but it's like
you know dude small fights like you know
you didn't pick up your [ __ ] or you know
I need a little bit more help with the
kids
yeah I know what I mean it's not you
know so we don't really get a chance to
yell at each other because the fight to
never go that long or they're not they
don't escalate to that point but yeah I
grew up with parents that yelled like
mad people like really crazy with it you
know what I mean and like my dad didn't
necessarily have to ever put his hands
on me all he had to do was raise his
voice and I knew he meant something I
knew it was real right i mean and just
watching him and my mom go at it and uh
yeah we try not to yell in front of our
kids you know but sometimes I get
excited sometimes I'll yell at the TV
like mother [ __ ] oh [ __ ] so even your
oh [ __ ] is oh [ __ ] Oh even my ocean
reception oh [ __ ] yeah like to watch
other parents hold their tongue in front
of their kids i try to but that's just I
mean he's a kid still and he's not when
I say [ __ ] he doesn't know up Sun Goes
Shh so oh my god well see my kid well I
was driving and he goes mommy why did
you say [ __ ] and I laughs I said I said
truck I lie I lie I lie so hard it
heartbeat right I lie all the time why
not all the time if it makes it so they
can have an easier life lie I mean until
he calls me out on it which he has he's
caught tuna he's caught he's called me
out in a couple yeah yeah yeah yeah
because like we were driving in the
canyons and there's just one you know a
little side street that I take where if
if you're going even three and a half
miles per hour it's like you're going
it's a head-on collision right it's at
the top of Mulholland Laurel you know
you take those sighs i knows you know it
means I'm like this car is just coming
around the corner I go [ __ ] knows what
and i go it's a truck luckily it was
like a jeep looking car it's a job this
truck Oh watch where you going mr. truck
right but then he caught me a couple
times he was asking me questions about
stuff like like we drove I think I might
have already talked about this Aaron we
drove by a cemetery you know the 405 you
can see the cemetery near UCLA yeah off
veteran yeah and it goes what's that
talk about this and he goes what's that
and I go oh that's that's called a
cemetery and he goes what what is it for
oh god I was like uh truck Oh truck me
uh that's where people go if you want to
remember someone that's answer is not
care you gotta yeah and i always ask him
what he thinks it is first right because
then i could i only have to offer up
information all right it's like when
your wife when you come home late in the
middle the night and your wife is like
where were you and then you go where do
you think i was that never works I know
what do you think only say what they
think well I think you were bowling I
was also totally rolling I'm so sorry
got carried away I've been bowling for a
while for a long time but I always asked
him like what do you think it is to see
what he even knows and and this time is
like I don't know and I go that sort of
people go to remember people right
because remember people for what I'm
like oh just yet you're gonna start
wearing blinders when we drive that's
what that's gonna happen yeah dude yeah
I never want to discuss death with my
kid I mean how does he my youngest boy
is gonna be three and so that's the last
thing I want to talk about with him yeah
he's not gonna ask quite yet for he'll
start asking but you're older kids they
know about that stuff right but when did
they start asking you uh right around
five six you know yeah uh you know
people started passing away and oh it
was that's the conversation that you
have to have when you know like when my
kids were young uh my my my aunt passed
away my you know like a bunch of people
in my life passed away and you know you
have to explain that stuff and what did
they what did you say I stayed you know
they're not here anymore or you know
it's hard dude it's like that because I
don't want them to ever feel like that
they have to worry about that with me at
least not right now okay I mean and so
it's like you know they went away and
you I'll totally see them will totally
see them again it just not right now you
know anything now forget about it
they're like that dudes dead
and I mean but as a youth it's like it's
hard to explain its real that's the
hardest thing I think to explain it you
know life and death you know I mean but
sometimes I you got to put fear and your
kids too so don't run out into the
street why cuz you'll get hit by a car
what happens if I get hit by a car big
trouble you're right well let me tell
you mommy and daddy are gonna be very
angry if you get hit by a car or you
know I mean dude I said to my kid other
day sometimes I'm such an idiot he's
jumping on our bed now our headboard is
soft and are in the footboard they're
both soft ish you know they're covered
in materials it's not just wood right
but still I go dude if you hit your neck
right here yes it's my five girl I go
it's lights out because what has lights
out me and then I realized what the
[ __ ] I'm going there right I go it
means we got to go to the hospital right
I need to stop talking to him like he's
a comic at the you know Laugh Factory I
talked to my kid like he's just our
stand up and we're just hanging out an
open mic well it'll have a great sense
of humor because of it well yes but have
great you also seek the approval of
drunk strangers right happiness is this
thing I know is this thing on you never
did stand up right I wish man I wish I
had the guts to do it I'm so afraid to
do it one because i don't think i can
write well enough to do it i know i
can't that's not one of us to
acknowledge that there's a writing
aspect yeah and to you know it's hard I
you know I've seen stand-ups crush and
I've seen them fall on their face and
falling on your face I I don't know how
you guys do it to be honest with you I
don't know how you guys get back up and
say you know what that was just once
said I'll get up and do another set
later well what do you think why do you
think we do that cuz you like it cuz
we're broken right you like it we broken
right we're broken people right yeah yes
yeah yes yeah that is the essence of it
in a great
though that's the thing it's in a great
way like I remember when I first found
out that a lot of chefs like famous
famous chefs that our culinary Masters
are also high on coke I was like why why
can't you just be a great chef right and
then someone said to me why can't comics
just be normal people and I go oh you're
right doc but I can't actors be normal
people to you know I hear know all the
time but it's a quick know you guys even
if when you hear no you got to continue
first slower now here's my joke no
here's I got another one no I don't be
up here for an hour let me tell you what
I tell a lot of new comics go do black
rooms right why because imagine cuz they
laugh at anything no no because they
were bare yeah with no problem yeah zero
yeah they don't feel better like oh just
feel my jam let's just do a nervous
laughter at least I did so many I
actually i'm doing the comedy union
which is not a strictly black room like
it used to be when it was mixed nuts
many moons ago but I was once in there
where I was not only the only white
person I was the only white woman calm I
mean it was like right nobody else right
and I went on stage and I was like all
right here we go I'm glad I went to an
all black high school right that'll at
least help well that's started do you
got a laugh from there and just yeah I
just did I talked about how I tried out
for cheerleading in an all-black high
school and I was only white girl and I
so you at least made it so that the
comedy was relatable it's funny when you
see comics go up on stage and just do
their bit in all black room that black
people can't relate to like I once saw
this comic and all black room talk about
his trip to Japan and how you know how
he was on the plane in first class etc
etc yep and and everyone was nodding
like oh we get it nobody no one people
you know and and this was a small room
and you know
I couldn't I just couldn't understand
like look you gotta have and it and he
was my friends friend right and you know
I thought it was funny because I could
relate I'm laughing my ass off you know
what I mean I'm black but I've been on a
plane you know what I mean most black
people have been on hold on before I
[ __ ] stick my foot deep down in my
mouth holy [ __ ] that came out wrong you
meant to say but like I was class I've
been first class you're gonna meet but
before I put me stick my foot even deep
in my mom I know black people have been
first class too so please do you know
what I'm saying man you've been to Japan
I've been I've never been to Japan so
what he's telling that story I couldn't
relate i was like i don't get it i don't
get it i don't get it but you know like
he has he obviously had different
experiences than the people in the
audience had and they weren't laughing
and he kept going and going and going
and going and it was like at some point
just say something that we can relate to
though because you're not you know
you're completely alienating us yeah and
just doing your bit and at least you had
something that you could go on stage to
say all right this is this would happen
in my life I know all y'all can relate
to this because I know you'll have a
white friend you know what I mean I know
it's all black room but you got a white
friend the first thing I said when I
went on stage will i tole everybody I
was tender-headed quick yeah me because
I had a really intense aggressive jewfro
when I was a kid gotcha I mean it was
like battle it would fight you right
answer head and I was tender headed
because that's only reason I knew that
was because the black girls that would
braid my hair would tell me right like
girl you tender-headed because I was
screaming in pain right and crying and
they would pull my hair so tight and the
braids and they were intense and I was
like I don't think I don't need to be a
white person in cornrows all right girl
you're crazy but if you had something
that do come late oh my god but I I'll
show you a picture of my lover see it is
absolutely right illegal okay it's so
it's you've seen it Aaron seen it
oh my god it's not even it's a frozen
like long curls like cuz oh so you think
I'm lying to you right now no I don't
think you're lying you're here pretty
straight right now though oh yeah
because I've learned are you learned
something yeah this is called the katt
williams right you flip it in the back
so this is actually me on a vet okay I
can't leave i'm even showing you this
but this is me on oh yeah yes it's so
frightening that's not really a frog
funny cuz it fell afro no fall no no
this was a fro like you could stick
stuff in it right you could pick it out
I never got fingered in high school just
so you know look at those eyebrows this
is like turn the plane oh no you were
cute though no no no this is what year
in high school this is actually not high
school this is actually 8th grade yes
I'm top ok this is frightening I'm
rather touch mustache everything I gotta
watch that oh hell yeah right on yeah
nice all right look you're gonna have to
cut some of these things out of 0 none
of it what why I said some [ __ ] up
[ __ ] about some people about black
people yes no we don't have to cut that
part out I don't necessarily think Hill
Harper wants people to know that he's
old man trying to front like he's a kid
how old is he like 60 and how does he
say he is 34 ok well then no we're
leaving at it ok cool there it is um I
know that you and your wife have a
healthy relationship and you still
lambton we lambton all that all the
times I'm gonna let you go so you can go
do that actually I'm gonna go to an
audition now oh yeah what are you
auditioning for can you talk about it I
can't talk about all right Star Wars no
I wish I wish I thought I'd be the best
day ever no because I know that you're a
huge that Aaron do you know that he's
such AI mean oh yeah we had a couple
star wars questions yeah I'm insanity
and he literally almost burst into tears
when they got him wrong oh my god I hate
that yeah I really hope it comes back so
do I we had a lot of fun back in it I
would
and I like that chicken yeah I know
chuck was really good two weeks yeah for
two weeks to get a check like that's
pretty cool it was nice I can get more
stuff I hope I'll channel to work
together again if not this something
else something else um do you know how
to act right yes whether it is that
we've seen you do extra work one I
please go to my IMDB I'm a chemistry
student number one were one erotic
confession not even chemistry student
number two you came out student number
one I ever that I was I was believable
yeah um um it's fun now now it's fun now
I can talk about it right um hey I might
have to go back to some erotic
confessions extra work you know get the
[ __ ] from these kids you never know
that's the crazy know where you never
know uh yeah can I talk a lot of talk
but I don't want my kids pass out sample
pictures no you don't you want to
freaking make that money it's hard to
listen man this in this town it's so
hard to stay afloat and everybody wants
you know everybody's gunning for your
spot no matter what so do you believe
there's enough for everyone yeah well
with all the channels that there are now
and all this special now uh definitely i
do believe there's enough for everyone
right now my husband did it get it he
works for a company where they represent
youtube stars hmm and these people are
not trying to get on GSN not trying to
get on any they make a hundred thousand
dollars a day on youtube add a day yay
yay how is that I days or they're
millionaires now oh one hundred percent
Wow and they don't and they're not even
they don't even care what you're
auditioning for or what I'm doing they
are doing their [ __ ] and so I do really
truly feel like there is enough for
everyone right I definitely I definitely
agree it depends on what your dreams are
too though you know some people have
dreams of being in movies that you know
paramount WB Disney uh you know line
that they put out you know some people
are fine with you know listen you can
pay me and nobody ever has to see what
I'm doing you know I mean before with
that to each other drugs i'll do it
what's happening are you offering me i'm
not offering you any drugs uh but you
know some people that's they're fine
with that uh you know
the problem is once you get a taste of
it if it ever goes away you're gonna
lose your [ __ ] and so you know that I'm
sure you've seen firsthand absolutely
i've experienced you know I've
experienced top of the world and not
working at all you know what I mean I've
been number one on the call sheet I've
been not on a call sheet in writing so
yeah it's it's a it's a it's a struggle
you know and and and i have so many kids
that you know it's a like that jamaican
say hey kids you got my got nine kids
month how many jobs you got i'm trying
to always have a job you know yeah and
you are always working it seems like
that but there are ton look I didn't
work at all last year other than when
Saturday you know what I mean and but
you know what it is you've you've you're
lucky that you've come to a place in
your career where you have this this
goodwill like you walk into any room and
you still have that right I'm still Who
I am right right so even though you know
you you might only work one job a year
it's probably more oh absolutely not
solutely I'm not sitting here saying
yeah broke please help me out now I'm
sitting thing is like look I want to
work yeah you know what I mean and it's
not just it's not I don't want to just
work for money I want to work like i
enjoy yeah you know I enjoy a grind I
enjoy the 925 right i mean right sort of
like it's sort of like a stand-up comic
you enjoy when you slay so you'll take
all of those freakin all the people that
are saying that you're not funny you're
not funny just for that one moment where
they're like oh my god I take it back I
take it back yeah I mean it's exactly
that it's you're chasin the dragon
constantly yeah you're chasing that last
hi yeah that last time you killed was
all that matters right and um I recently
audition for something I got a callback
which was nice nice and then I didn't
get it and I came home that day and I
knew I didn't [ __ ] get it I knew it
and my my kid was like mommy one day I
want to be a whatever he wanted to be in
that moment actually he said I'm gonna
be a rock star and I said and I was like
feeling so shitty even though I really
don't hold on to it is like what I used
to hold on to it right but in that
moment
like [ __ ] I know I didn't get that what
I wanted I go you can be anything you
wanna be I wanted to be like oh yeah I
guess what life is gonna open up your
mouth and [ __ ] down your throat you can
do anything good anything is possible I
didn't [ __ ] get back right I just you
know it's hard yeah to balance that it's
all hard it's a mean life is hard life
is it's not meant to be easy I guess but
you know when you find your lane or you
find your wave you ride it until you
can't ride it anymore then you go back
out into the ocean and find another one
you know that's how I look at it and my
black people don't swim is what you're
saying no but you but if with a
surfboard but with a surfboard but you
say like I can stay afloat surf two
means that we no no no no no I'm saying
if they had to choose between just them
in the water and them in the water with
the surfboard I think they're gonna go
with those are poor because it's you
know it's lucious ok but no black people
don't serve but that was not no no no no
no but if given a situation where they
were like look jump off the boat you can
either swim or here's a surfboard
they're gonna take the surfboard can I
tell you how proud I am that my not
proud that I had you know but my my son
and my one-year-old not only have they
seen a black president but black hockey
players crazy right the hockey players
blows my mind more than president yeah
because first of all I don't skate dude
and the fact that there's somebody black
out that I can skate had like some cold
weather kills it the heck yes the black
person that likes co I'm gonna get in so
much trouble for this but I'm gonna do I
was gonna I'm just gonna keep going with
it no uh yeah I remember when there was
just only one black hockey player anyone
in the Kings with the Kings or was he
like on the Bruins or something like
that my back was not on the Kings Oh
back in the day I'm not recently okay I
think he was traded but well he was
actually a good player that was great
he's actually a really good player yeah
the one back in the day was just a
enforcer so they would put him in just
to fight and that was it
I'm just putting it up I'm not from what
I remember from what I remember I don't
know enough about hockey I don't watch
enough hockey wait a second get rushing
them you don't know about hockey I know
I know let me tell you I could cry when
my husband who loves hockey my dad who
knows hi when they bond over hockey yeah
I just sit there and I'm like the
world's gonna be okay it's gonna be okay
they're bonding yeah yeah all right I
don't want to keep you it's all good
that's with Anya uh let's go get
pedicures together soon I would like
that you like massage i do when i walked
in i should have said pretty viet their
deviant privyet that's women yes I went
back in a day I did a thing called free
to be a family and we did a space bridge
to Russia to Moscow actually what I had
a Russian pen pal for about a month and
I what yes and I learned some things
like Mowgli bleep wheat eie t e te amo
babe we bleed odd noise enjoy I'm saying
good night so that was our talk I hope
he books whatever he goes out he's gone
out for today I hope he books it and I
hope you guys come out and check me out
live in person are you in Los Angeles by
any chance on sunday august twenty-first
great i'll be at The Comedy Store on
Sunset Boulevard Oh can't make it how
about are you in LA Wednesday August
twenty-fourth i'll be at the hollywood
laugh factory that night no you can't
make that either are you in dallas texas
maybe that'll work saturday august 27th
also erin's wedding
Aaron I'm at the house of blues with
ahmed ahmed dallas texas saturday august
27 come out come out yeah and other
dates to come other dates to talk about
but let's talk about what's really
important you did this to me please oh
please they haven't already seen it go
to amazon go to itunes go to Google Play
go to Lulu again I haven't checked I
have to check go to places that you
watch streaming things you did this to
me my one hour special I shot it seven
months pregnant it's a super fun super
funny please support it leave a nice
review that makes all the difference in
the world and also don't forget to watch
win sanity on Thursday nights with
myself and the host Donald Faison all
right kids I'll talk to you extent by
you